dans la forêt de saint germain en laye
samedi matin les températures sont
plutôt fraîches et pourtant une
vingtaine de personnes est venue
participer aux buttes campe une création
de l'armée américaine on rentre le
ventre on prépare la place 2019
inspiré des entraînements militaires les
participants enchaînent les exercices
intensifs de renforcement musculaire et
de cardio c'est sympa ça change de
l'ordinaire de la chance parce que il
peut pas donc
non ça s'entend ça fait travailler un
peu tout car jolis muscles du sport en
plein air c'est c'est génial ça fait du
bien l'air tout un groupe sympa au bonne
ambiance c'est chouette
[Musique]
place à présent à l'activité de
brancardage puis parcours d'obstacles
qui s'inspire de celui des combattants
de l'armée de terre et tout ça sous les
ordres des encadrants confié de
formation
le plus compliqué on va dire c'est de
s'adapter à chaque niveau de personnes
et de créer des parcours uniforme on ne
veut pas qu'ils aient des gens qui
soient laissés sur le côté on veut que
on est vraiment cet esprit de groupe et
de camaraderie entre les adhérents
le dépassement de soi l'une des
motivations principales des participants
à l'occasion de ce bout de campagne
forêt de saint-germain-en-laye tout son
groupe comme ça ça motive c'est on sent
qu'on aura on s'encourage les uns des
autres
puis faire simple pleine nature avec les
oiseaux qui chantent way le ciel qui est
pas trop mauvais c'est magique près
recommencé préparation pour une échéance
défi sportif ou petite leçon de vie tous
les participants se souviendront de leur
bout de caen